NEIL: ALL RIGHT, WELL DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS MIGHT NOT ALL BE
ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN IT COMES
TO COVID-19 RELIEF, BUT THEY
APPEAR TO BE UNANIMOUSLY AGAINST
FACEBOOK AND CHARGING THAT IT
HAS SIMPLY GOTTEN TOO BIG FOR
ITS BRITCHES, SOME 46
ATTORNEYS GENERAL AT A MINIMUM
PART OF A CLASS ACTION BATTLE
AGAINST FACEBOOK THAT SAYS IT IS
SIMPLY BECOME NOT ONLY TOO BIG
BUT ANTI-TRUST PROBLEM.
THE LIKES OF WHICH IT HAS RARELY
SEEN OR  SOME OF THESE ATTORNEYS
GENERAL HAVE RARELY SEEN
CERTAINLY IN RECENT HISTORY.
JOSH STEIN JOINS US RIGHT NOW
THE NORTH CAROLINA DEMOCRATIC
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHO IS KIND
ENOUGH TO JOIN US ON THIS
SATURDAY.
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
NEIL: WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER ONE
AND PRIMARY BEEF AND 45 OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES, ABOUT THE WAY
FACEBOOK DOES ITS BUSINESS?
>> YEAH, WELL FACEBOOK IS A
MONOPOLY.
THEY ABSOLUTELY DOMINATE THE
SOCIAL NETWORKING SITE SPACE
WHICH WE’VE ALL COME TO DEPEND
ON.
I MEAN, THEY WERE MASSIVE AND
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BUT SINCE WE’VE
LIVED SO MUCH OF OUR LIVES ON
THE INTERNET NOW IT’S HOW WE
CONNECT WITH OUR AUNTS, UNCLES,
OUR FRIENDS, CLASSMATES, ALL OF
THAT, AND THEY’VE USED THAT
MASSIVE POWER WHICH THEY HAVE AS
A MONOPOLY TO MAINTAIN IT.
THEY SQELCHED COMPETITION AND
THAT HURTS CONSUMERS SO WHAT WE
WANT IS TO SEE FREE COMPETITION
IN THE SOCIAL NETWORKING SITE
SPACE SO THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
MEANINGFUL CHOICE.
NEIL: SO BREAK THEM UP?
>> THAT COULD BE PART OF IT.
WHAT WE WANT IS FOR THE COURT TO
BLOCK THEM, FIRST OF ALL, FROM
ENGAGING IN ANY ANTI-COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR GOING FORWARD, TO
REQUIRE FACEBOOK TO NOTIFY THE
STATE A.G. BEFORE THEY DO
MORE ACQUISITIONS, AND WHATEVER
RELIEF IS NECESSARY AND THAT
COULD INCLUDE DIVESTING LINES OF
BUSINESS.
WE’LL HAVE TO FIGURE ALL THAT
OUT AS WE GO FORWARD WITH THE
CASE.
NEIL: TECHNOLOGY ALWAYS CHANGES
AS YOU KNOW, SIR, AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THE VILLAIN
YOU SEE TODAY COULD BE JUST THE
DINOSAUR TOMORROW, AND THAT
IS JUST A WASTE OF TIME WHAT DO
YOU SAY?
>> WELL, I DISAGREE.
TECHNOLOGY DOES CHANGE ALL THE
TIME, BUT WHEN SOMEBODY GROW
S AND FACEBOOK BROUGHT ALL
MANNER OF INNOVATION TO
SOCIAL NETWORKING.
WHEN THEY GROW WHATEVER THEY’RE
BRINGING TO THE MARKET IF ONCE
THEY BECOME THE MONOPOLY THEY
THEN USE THAT POWER TO KEEP
ANYONE ELSE FROM EMERGING,
THAT’S WHAT VIOLATES THE LAW.
IT’S NOT THE FACT THAT THEY’RE
BIG.
IT’S THAT THEY’RE USING THEIR
MONOPOLY POWER TO SQUELCH THAT
COMPETITION AND DEGRADE THE
SERVICE FOR CONSUMERS AND
THE PRIVACY PROTECTION
DIMINISHED AND THE FAKE ACCOUNTS
EXPLODED.
NEIL: GOT IT SO THE BATTLE GOES
ON I DON’T MEAN TO JUMP ON YOU